Adi Levanon Chazan,
I'm so happy we're finally doing this.
Thank you for the time.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
This is gonna be so much fun
and there's so much
that I want to talk about,
but first I want to start
with your journey
because just going over your background,
I got overwhelmed by seeing
the number of different places
that you've gone
through the venture capital firms,
to product at companies, and then
back to venture capital firms
across continents.
So Adi, dumb it down for me.
How do you get
to where you are now at Flint Capital
and helping invest in Israel,
but also previously in New York.
Talk to me about your journey.
Yeah, for sure.
So, I'm American originally.
I'm actually from your neck
of the woods right now.
So I grew up in Palo Alto.
Parents were Israeli.
Moved to Israel when I was 12
with the family,
and basically everything I've done
after the army was either in startups
or in venture capital in some shape or form.
I'm a lawyer, but I don't practice.
So I guess some call it a recovering lawyer.
And yeah, I mean, I think
I've been in different places
because I've just been fortunate
basically every time to get
more exposure, more responsibility.
I started off, like I said, as a lawyer,
at the one of Israel's
first billion dollar Internet companies,
called Conduit.
I start up there as legal counsel,
and then I moved on
to manage the compliance team.
Michael, you're on mute.
Thank you very much.
When you go to study law
and you go to law school,
do you go there with the perception
that you want to be a lawyer later on
at a tech company?
Or do you just say,
Okay, I want to be a lawyer
because I'm interested in law?
Yeah. It's a really good question.
So, I can give you my perspective, right,
'cause it's only from my point of view.
But I always, I think for me,
the way I got to where I am now
is basically I always think
a few steps ahead.
So, I kind of knew in my mind
that even though I liked law
and enjoyed it,
the things I liked most
were contract law and business law.
So, I knew that even if I would join
as legal counsel, I always had the desire
to go to the business side at some point
which I think
is why I became legal counsel
as my first job as a lawyer.
And I basically went down that road.
Right?
So, from legal counsel at the company,
then I managed a compliance team
which in many ways was a combination of,
between law,
but also a lot of business
and also very technical.
I managed a team
of developers, and analysts,
and I worked with all the R&D teams.
Yeah. And at that time we had
two main clients,
were Google and Microsoft Bing.
So I kind of had to be the, in many ways,
the bottleneck with regards
to any kind of new product or any kind of
major partnership that we had.
Yeah. So, it was pretty cool in that sense.
So, what it sounds to me is that
you're taking this,
you're starting out as a lawyer,
you're joining a billion dollar company,
Conduit, in Israel.
And then you go and you work
with huge clients,
and that put you in the position
where you're in the intersection
between the tech and the compliance.
And you're getting the exposure,
both of the R&D,
but also from your background.
And slowly you're moving yourself
to the business.
And then how do you go to product
and venture capital from there?
So first there was,
I'm in venture capital,
so I moved on to Rhodium from there,
which you know also that ...
he was part of the team
and Daniel Recanati obviously
and ...
So I moved on to there.
I actually got my first leg into VC
as a student at IDC,
at IDC Herzliya,
actually working for what was then
Cardinal Ventures
is now Viola.
So I worked there actually as a student.
At some point, I did like almost 75%
of a position while I was doing
two degrees.
So that's my first picture
in the world of VC.
And then, when I heard from a friend
actually for a portfolio company at Rhodium,
they were looking for somebody
to join the team, the investment team.
I was like, Okay. This is where I want to go.
I had that just hunger
to enter that space.
I thought it was so interesting.
I heard about it from my parents
'cause they were always in tech,
and just I was like,
I need to go down that route.
And yeah, I was really fortunate.
I think that a lot of what I went through
in compliance managing teams,
like you said,
and working with R&D teams
really helped me then
when I met with founders at Rhodium.
So Adi, I want you to take me back
a little bit
and give me the pivotal moments
in your upbringing where,
because right now you're one of the
most popular investors in Israel.
- Thank you
And I've been recommended to talk to you
on this show from so many people
that I can't even count anymore.
Thank you.
So I'm curious. At the end, one of the things
I'm curious about is what helps a person
get to where they are today?
Is it just their passion?
Is it opportunities
that they were seizing?
Is it motivation?
So, what were some of the pivotal moments
that you really became passionate
and you knew, I want to devote myself
to the work that I'm doing?
I think it's a really good question.
I mean, it's a lot of the things
you said, right?
So first, people who know me
know I'm a very passionate person.
I get very very excited about things
that I believe in, sometimes too much.
But I'm very very excited about things
I'm passionate about.
And I think that passion
is something that is contagious.
So I think that helps
when you meet people,
they see that you want something
and you're interested,
I think that's helped.
But in many ways,
to get to where you want to go,
I mean, I say this a lot,
I think you really need to be open
to meeting people,
be open to hearing other people's stories,
and learn from their stories
what works for you and what doesn't.
Like I've always done my homework before
every step I took, whether it was
I moved to New York, I had nothing, right?
Like, I had nothing.
I had family and everything,
but in New York,
I didn't come with a partner.
I had maybe knew three people.
I didn't have an apartment.
I didn't have a job.
But I came very structured.
And I think everything I've done
was always very structured.
Like I said, I always thought
a few steps ahead.
So like where do I want to go,
and how do I get there.
And I think having a structure,
and passion, and talking to people,
and not being, having that grit, like not being shy.
I was almost saying ashamed.
But it's not about being ashamed,
it's not being shy to reach out to people.
I've reached out to partners,
really large VC funds in New York
before I moved and said,
"I'm moving. This is my background.
I'd love to have coffee."
And in many cases, it worked.
And I really believe that, I mean
it worked for me then,
and I really believe that also today.
So, I hope that answers your question.
It definitely does.
And my follow up question
is why venture capital?
It sounds like
with your passion and consistency,
you can choose any job
you want in the world,
yet you choose to focus
on venture capital. Why do that
instead of continuing to another company
or creating your own company?
It's a good question.
I love venture. I love this job.
I love the ability to,
I'm a very curious person,
so I love the fact that I get to meet
so many different people
with so many different ideas
and learn from them.
My curiosity is constantly fed
on a daily basis,
which really intrigues me.
And I really love
being able to be helpful and be impactful,
and I think that
that's a lot of what we do.
I mean not every fund does that,
not every investor does that.
But people that know me,
I think founders that know me,
like I try hard to work, I work for them.
And I think that,
at least I see it that way,
hopefully that they will agree.
But that's how I kind of view it.
So, trying to be helpful.
And I think that, in the end of the day,
the combination of a financial business
In the end of the day,
we are an asset class
like any other in many ways.
But being able to bring something
that's beneficial and brings money,
but also impacts the world
hopefully in a positive way
makes me feel really good,
and that gets me up in the morning.
And of course, I think
that working for a startup is fantastic.
And who knows
what will happen in the future,
but in general, I love this job.
I think for me also, I love the fact
that I see different things.
I've had opportunities in the past
to join, even I was in New York,
to join portfolio companies as a COO
and things like that.
And I just thought, "I'll come in
and I'll do this and it'll be great"
But after six months,
I think I'll be like,
"Okay, what's next?"
Not because it's not interesting,
but I do like touching different things
at once. That's just me personally.
That's so so cool. Okay.
So now, talking about journeys
and I'd love to talk
about one of the things
that you're really passionate about:
diversity in tech.
And I think, on one hand,
it's a subject that is being spoken about
more and more in our domain.
On the other hand,
it's definitely not spoken about enough.
And not enough has been done
to bring that, to level the playing field.
And as a mother,
and as an ambitious career woman,
I'd love to hear your take on
where are we at today,
and what do you think needs to happen
in order to level the playing field
much more than what is being done today?
So fantastic question.
So, I think there is a shift,
but it's a little bit
I mean it's slow, right?
I mean, my point of view has been
for a while is that, if we don't
I mean, there's some people
that focus on the top down approach,
okay, which is we need to start
from schools.
We need to start educating.
We need to start, even in the form
of removing biases.
There's this known,
I forget what type of bias it's called,
I think it's the acceptance bias
if I'm not mistaken, I don't remember.
But, you're not gonna think
about a doctor versus being a female
unless you see many female doctors.
Right?
There's something about
having that vision in front of you
that helps children
at the end of the day,
think that they can be
the next founder, the next CEO,
the next astronaut etc. etc.
So, some people focus on that
and I think
that's really really important.
I really believe that in our world
it needs to come top down,
and I'm not the only one that thinks this,
but I've wrote a few post about it.
And I think that, the problem is is that
we don't have enough people at the top
that trickle down and say,
Okay. Either I'm a CEO of a Fortune 500,
or I'm a wealthy individual,
or whatever it may be,
I have the opportunity
to be impactful and be helpful.
But do I actually do anything
to bring more women in to sit next to me?
And that just, it's not enough.
And I think it's shifting.
But from my mind, it's like I,
just as an example.
I started, it's not even
a very very organized process,
but I started something within,
there's some female investors in Israel,
a few funds.
They started this VC group of women in VC.
And there were like 40 something of us.
And I said, you know there's so many pitch events
all the time.
Yeah, it's a lot.
I think they're more than 40 now.
I think there's near 50
which is fantastic.
So that, in it of itself,
shows that there is a shift.
But hold on. That I think is great.
And because I noticed that we have such
amazing power in this platform,
let's go and just do pitch events,
or office hours some places call it,
for female founders.
And we've been doing it
for a few months now
and it's been fantastic.
But the reason why I'm so excited about it
is a few things.
I think that it's really important
that more female VCs make decisions,
because if we're not making the decisions
and we're not part
of the investment committee,
of the actual decisions and check writing,
we're not gonna get to that place
of being a partner, and then
maybe later in the day
becoming an LP ourselves
or angel investor, etc.
So, that's in one hand from the VC side.
And then obviously, helping the founders,
female founders who statistically
we know they have a harder time
raising money, have a better opportunity
from women that they usually don't meet
at the table.
So, both sides of that,
I think is really crucial,
but it really needs to come from the top.
We need more LPs that are women.
We need more CEOs to be women.
We just need more people
that have capital and access
and the ability to make decisions
to start making it for women.
And not just women, by the way.
Any diversity.
Whether it's in Israel,
I would say Arabs and Ethiopians
and whatever it may be.
People with disabilities,
it doesn't matter.
100%. 100%.
One of the things
that I've been contemplating,
here in California, being in the midst
of the Black Lives Matter movement.
One of the things that dawned on me,
and the movement is talking all about,
not the fact that the black lives matter,
everybody knows that,
but it's more specific than that.
It's saying that people
that are not minority,
that have what they call white privilege,
we have an innate responsibility
not only to not be racist,
but to actually take action against it.
Right?
So, being a bystander
is a part of the problem.
And I think that
what you're saying here top down,
and being, as a decision maker,
not saying that you promote diversity,
but actually taking action
and speaking out about that.
So, I think that's something
that's definitely true.
But Adi, I also want to talk about
a little bit about investing.
So coming in, I'm having
the time of my life with Oded Hermoni
at J-Ventures.
And as I'm understanding the world
a little bit better,
one thing that is very evident is that
different places around the world
invest in different ways.
And as I get to speak to leaders
from different areas in the world,
I get to hear
about the different mindsets.
You have the unique privilege of seeing
both the New York side and Tel Aviv side.
And I'd love to hear a little bit
about your investment thesis
and how do you approach opportunities,
and what are some of the key questions
that you're thinking about?
So just to take a little bit of a step back.
So, in general, Flint capital
is a global fund.
So we invest out of Israel,
but we also invest in the US and Europe.
And before that,
I worked for two funds in New York
that one, both of them, I mean one of them
was actually kind of global, FinTech Collective
has a global point of view and a
global thesis on investing
in FinTech companies.
And then Symmetrical Ventures
we invested just in companies in the US.
So, I've had the opportunity to invest
in startups that are located
in New York, Atlanta, LA,
Silicon Valley, but also here in Tel Aviv.
So that's just in general.
So, I think I've been fortunate
to really have a perspective
on different ecosystems,
which I think is really important.
Right.
What I'll say is this.
I think that, and this is not just a plug,
I think this is something
that's really important about investing
is the fact that
we are, as Flint Capital,
we have an opportunity to be here.
Right
I'm the only person here in Israel
in the investment team.
But we have a partner in Boston,
I think that you know ...
So he comes out here often,
or before covid he came here often.
But the ability to be East Coast
and West Coast,
to be in different ecosystems
and have information
from different ecosystems,
and being able to see what's happening,
get information,
understand the different VCs,
understand the different leaders,
is really really important.
And I think that that's one thing.
I would say that investing here
is very different than in the States
in a few ways. I mean I think it's just
what funds look for, right?
There is, I'll give you an example,
and this is gonna be very. I mean,
and this might not sound weird to you
because you said people out of 8200
and the like, so I think that
in Israel there is a lot of that,
which is also not good
when we think about diversity, right?
Diversity is not just about
male or female.
It's just about being different in general.
So I think that in Israel, there's a lot
of this copy-paste sometimes,
where you can find
very talented individuals
that came out of prime minister's office
or 8200 or any one of the other,
9900, any one of these fantastic units,
and then they have not much experience,
very tech based, but they're like,
this is what I'm doing.
I can't tell you what I'm doing,
but I'm raising money.
And then the expectation
is for me to be like, I'm in.
And by the way, many funds will be.
Now, I understand
because when you're very smart technically
and you have so much experience
and you can get very far. You can.
But I don't think that in the States
you will see so much of that in general.
Somebody coming out of MIT
or Carnegie Mellon or the like,
and being like, now we're gonna throw
five million dollars because,
or I don't know,
even if you came out of some elite unit
in the US Army,
I don't think that it would be the same.
Because essentially, as you know
and I know, I think in the States
and I think also funds here know that too,
that it's really really important
to have the business acumen.
To understand positioning.
To understand
how you're going to sell your company.
And I think that
that is a bit of a difference.
But, from the other hand,
the reason why that works in Israel
is because it's a small ecosystem.
And we know each other.
And it's easy to get that,
to get the viewpoint on people,
understand that
they have the capabilities.
And then, I think that what's good now
is that, good or bad we can discuss.
Some people see it differently.
A lot of funds, they have now
this network that they provide
to the founders.
Right.
And to help them get
to where they get to go,
anywhere they need to go.
It's different.
It's just very very different.
But I think that there is
more camaraderie.
I mean, in New York,
I was super impressed.
Like I think I loved it
that we were sharing between each other.
VCs, super ...
I don't know if it's like that
in the Valley. In New York.
- I didn't expect that.
I don't know, the people that I met
and the funds that I met, investors,
we would share information.
If I saw something interesting,
what do you think about this,
what are your thoughts,
what are you looking at.
It was a lot of sharing
for the sake of working together
and getting feedback,
especially in the FinTech funds at least.
I don't know, but not just, not just.
And I think here, that's happening too,
but it depends, again, which sectors.
Some of them are more like,
let's keep it in stealth mode
and not really share.
So, I think those are the differences.
And I think it's really important
for founders when they think about,
always think up, like I said before,
thinking few steps ahead.
So when you get your seed investor,
I would always think about,
or even your pre-seed,
but think about who you want to be
around the table for your A
and how to get there.
And I think that's really important.
I think that one of the things
that you mentioned so resonated with me,
because I spent four and a half years
in one of those units in the IDF.
And then I came here to Stanford
to continue my studies
and continue enriching my own knowledge
both in engineering, but also in business
and scaling products
and obviously with J-Ventures.
And one of the key distinctions,
like you mentioned, is I'm seeing
in the IDF, we're sitting down,
we're doing computer science.
Really really great advanced technology
for many years.
And then a lot of my friends go out
and they build startups.
Here, all of a sudden at Stanford,
the first class we have
is introduction to deep learning.
The second class
is how to scale your product.
It's constantly intertwined.
What often we find, though, is that,
and I've talked to quite
a few professors here and they mentioned
that oftentimes a Technion graduate,
or a graduate of the unit, has more skills
than a Stanford or MIT graduate
which is interesting.
But obviously leads to,
No. No. Of course.
I mean, that's why it does work.
I think that what we get in the army
is you can't get that
in many other places for sure.
But it's, I think you'll agree with me,
it's not the same as
exactly as working in a company
and growing within and doing an internship
at somewhere in the States.
I think the best thing
to be able to do, this
is some crazy idea
I had once, is that if we could get
Israelis the opportunity,
Israelis out of the army,
the opportunity to work for two years,
at a ray of fortune 100 companies
as a tech job for two years,
learn what it's like to be
in these companies and they can decide
if they want to stay or they want to go
and build their own thing.
But get that network,
get that knowledge, and get the expertise
of what it's like to work
in corporate America
because that'll be so beneficial
for their next cyber company
or whatever company they'll do.
That sounds amazing.
Adi, I can't believe
we're almost at 20 minutes.
And I have to spend the last few minutes
understanding you a little bit better.
And I'd love to ask simply
a difficult question.
What are you passionate about?
Why do you wake up every morning
and look at deals
and do the work that you do?
What are you really passionate about
right now?
So, I mean, there is the
what we do in the fund, right?
I mean, we invest and we look at companies
that are data driven.
Any company that has some form
of cognitive technology.
I'm gonna drop the buzzwords,
but there is a meaning behind it.
So, we do like companies
that are AI-based, NLP,
whatever it will be
in the world of cognitive tech.
But why is that interesting?
We really believe, and I myself as well,
the ability to use technology,
as you know very well,
to make our lives better.
To make our lives easier.
To make certain processes
that we didn't think about exist.
Or to take processes that didn't work
and just make them work better and well,
and obviously have a business around it.
I personally, obviously I'm excited
about those businesses
that also have some benefit
to humanity as well.
And it doesn't need to be impact.
Right?
Like if you're a company that obviously,
you're helping me with continue to work
out of the office in a very easy, secure way,
okay, that also does good for me.
- Of course.
But I think that being able to
But like, for example,
what I liked about FinTech,
specifically, is that, and I still do,
is that there really is a way to invest
in a company that is financially focused,
that wants to work within
the world of finance,
but you're helping the underbanked
the unbanked, emerging markets.
You're doing things that you didn't think
you were necessarily doing
and you're making an impact
even if you ... think you actually were.
So, to me, that's always
very very interesting and important.
And I think that,
and what gets me up in the morning,
like I said, is just being able
to be a part of that.
To be able to meet these individuals.
There's that moment
when you meet that entrepreneur,
whether female or male,
and you're like, "Holy wow.
This is just the right team.
I have to invest in this"
I mean there's a company right now
that I'm looking at
that I hope we close the deal.
I can't give
too much information obviously,
but they're focusing
on such a big, important market
that touches each and every one of us
and the technology's super strong.
But I mean, when I will share it with you
hopefully, and we do hopefully invest,
you're gonna hear about it and be like,
Wow. Like this is so, it seems so simple,
but it's so important.
And it's so different.
And when you meet something like that,
where it's a big, big market
and really, really pain.
And it's not just a pain to a few people,
it's a pain to all of us
like in our hearts.
I think that it's like
you just want to invest.
You want to be a part of that journey
and be helpful.
And yeah, what gets me up
also in the morning, is my baby.
I love that.
I love both answers.
And those deals are rare, right?
I mean, it's not every day
- So rare.
that you meet a team like this.
And I'm good friends here
with Dror Berman
from Innovation Endeavors,
and every time I go to their offices
and I look at their board of investments
and I asked Dror, like,
"What are you excited about?"
And he shares with me a new deal,
and then to the outsider,
it seems that yeah,
there is all these amazing amazing deals
that come all the time,
but it's not true
and I'm seeing it at J-Ventures.
It's hard to find those deals.
They're very rare.
They're very competitive.
But at the end, being a partner
on a company that makes a good impact
on the world, on a product that scales
and touches people's lives,
that's what I'm on my journey hopefully
to do one day.
You're doing it.
Hippo was a great example.
I mean, Hippo is, yes, it's insurance,
but you're helping people
have a better security in their lives.
And Assaf Wand is just the best ever.
That's a company I wanted to invest in.
Sitting here, one of the things
that I love about covid,
and I hope he watches this
because he's helping sponsor this show,
is that I get to sit next to him
in an empty office of 200 people,
and I just get to watch him work.
And while I'm coding away the product,
- Bulldozer
I'm just listening in.
By the way, he's one of the people
I met him when he was raising,
I think, his seed in New York.
He came to FinTech Collective,
and I told him this: everything he said
he would do, he's basically done.
So, hats down to him.
- Unbelievable
Adi, three words that you would use
to describe yourself
because you already have a meeting
with your female VC colleague.
Yeah. Yeah. Wow.
Three words to describe myself.
Passionate.
Yes
Loyal.
Okay.
Energetic, I guess.
I love it. I love it.
Passionate, loyal and energetic.
Adi, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Toda to you. Thank you so much.
You're doing such a great job.
And I'm looking forward
to maintaining this relationship
and continuing to learn over the years.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Bye.